Okay, I think we can start. I know it's
the end of the day, so I guess most of
you are already tired. How was your day,
by the way, so far? Pretty good.
Managed to survive the the many master
classes. Okay, so welcome. Good
afternoon everyone. Uh my name is Panos
Alexopoulos and today's master class
will be going to be will be about uh
knowledge graphs, LLMs and retrieval
augmented generation.
So the question first how many of you
have been working with knowledge graphs
already?
Okay then I don't I will will not have a
lot of new things there. How many of you
have been working with LMS in general?
Yeah. And what about rag?
Okay, what about graph rag?
Okay, here that's that makes sense. So
the whole idea of this workshop is to to
be directed to discuss also your
experiences, my experiences, right? It's
not about me telling you what works and
what doesn't. So
just a bit of introduction on myself. So
I've been working in the area of data
semantics, ontologies, knowledge graph
etc since around 2006. So far before the
era of machine learning and far before
the era of large language models. Um
since 2016 so for the last nine years
I'm a head of ontology in a company
called text in the in the Netherlands uh
where I lead a team that builds a large
knowledge graph about the recruitment
and HR domain. So the company builds
software for analyzing CVS and job
vacancies and matching them together. So
as part of our technology stack we have
a a large cross-lingual knowledge graph
that models information and knowledge
about occupation, skills, education etc.
Uh in 2020 I published a book with which
is a field guide for semantic data
modelers and it's practically a high
level conceptual guide that tackles uh
issues that we knowledge engineers,
semantic modelers, data modelers face as
I call it in the trenches. So when you
work right more than academic work
especially when it comes to to pitfalls
and dilemas and since last year I have
founded tech which is a company that
focuses on developing h and delivering
courses for professionals in data and
AI. This masterass is a sample of what
old tech does what kind of of training
we we offer.
Okay. So why we're here the starting
point for this talk is of course large
language models. Right. So I don't think
that there's anyone in here that as I
saw that has no idea what a large
language model is. But for the sake of
it let's just reiterate a bit. So a
large language model is practically
sophisticated deep learning model which
is based on an architecture called
transformers. And uh they're models that
are designed to understand and generate
humanlike text. They have been
pre-trained on massive uh data sets that
contain text mostly from the internet
and perhaps some other other documents
and some of them are potentially
fine-tuned for specific tasks although
the majority are just generic uh models
and they're used for a lot of things uh
including related to natural language
like text generation text classification
extraction sentiment analysis
translation etc.
Perhaps the most
attractive and alluring characteristic
of LLM is the way we interact with them
as opposed to, you know, having to work
with a very complex user interface where
you have to press buttons where you have
to give custom input in XML or in some
other code or maybe write a structure
query in SQL or in cipher or in sparkle.
uh with an LLN you just express in
natural language what you want to get as
as an answer or what output you want to
get right and since their uh emergence
with a whole let's say subfield has
emerged called prompt engineering which
which is the practice I would say I
don't think it's a science yet and I
don't think it will ever become a
science so it's the the practice of
trying to optimize uh the way we erh uh
he instructs the LMS what we want them
to do, right? How what is the best way
to write prompts that will give us
things in a way that is clear, in a way
that is ambiguous, in a way that uh will
result into what we actually uh need.
Prompts can contain instructions, can
contain input data, can contain
examples, and contain questions of
course. Right? Here's an example where
we describe a task. The task is about
sentiment analysis. So we say to the LLM
this is a movie review send classifier
and we give it examples of input and
output right and we expect it to based
on a few examples to tell us in new
situations what is uh what is the the
result that we expect.
There are many applications uh of many
tasks that an LLM can or at least is
used for nowadays, right? And to some
extent they replace a lot of traditional
or at least they claim to be able to
replace traditional systems and
applications that we used to do with
other types of methods with supervised
machine learning or with other types of
learning. So question answering is one
task for instance. Another is entity
extraction which is actually very
relevant for the task of knowledge graph
constructions etc. Right? So we can give
it a text and we can ask it to get to
extract for us uh entities, relations,
attributes etc.
And they can even write code right or at
least they they try to write and uh this
is a big use case in in the area of
software engineering and as and as we
will see later also in the field of
semantic modeling the field of ontology
engineering they can be used as well as
let's call them copilots for uh modeling
things into neoforj into RDF etc.
Now
the bad things
there's a lot of criticism about las
models and um there are among the many
problems there are many three main
limitations that have been observed the
first and perhaps most famous is the
so-called hallucination problem right
the thing is that LLMs are designed to
generate humanlike text based on the
patterns they have identified in vast
amounts of data
because Because of that sometimes they
hallucinate that is they may they
produce outputs that are not true
and
and not only that but they also um
assert them with a very high confidence.
So it's not that they say you know I'm
not very sure about that this might be
correct. They say you know this is
definitely correct and can be something
really absurd. Hence the the term
hallucination. And even worse, when you
try to ask them to explain themselves
like, okay, why did you get this output?
They might give you an an explanation
that is also nonsensical or even
inconsistent with the the initial the
initial output.
Why is that happening? It's because of
their very nature of the very way they
have been trained. Right? It's a mix of
overfeitting biases in training data and
generally the fact that they have been
optimized when when an LLM is trained it
is not optimized for correctness.
There's no ground truth against which
they are trained. They are just trained
to predict the next word the next what
can go later.
A second problem second limitation of
large language models is the so-called
knowledge cutff problem.
to train a large a large language model
takes a lot of resources, takes a lot of
data, takes a lot of energy, right?
Takes a lot of money in the end. So it's
not an LLM is very hard to provide a new
version every week, every month, every
every three months. Which means that for
every model that is out there right now
GPT uh clone etc there is a date cut of
date as it's called after which uh any
new knowledge that has been produced is
most likely not
most likely has not been used for to be
for the training of the model that means
that any knowledge
uh after that is not in the LLM
Then the other issue with cut off is
that because most of the lengths have
been trained on public data hopefully
most they are not um trained with the
data that the organization has which are
private right uh because of competition
because of of privacy issues etc. which
means that any knowledge about private
or confidence information will not be
available before the knowledge even
before the knowledge cut of date.
A third issue is the explanation problem
as as the overall this is a general
problem in machine learning and deep
learning uh and it's the fact that we
get an output and we have no idea why
what is the process through which it was
produced. If it's correct we're okay. If
it's wrong, right? And even if we see
it's wrong, we really it's very hard for
us to know for the end user to know what
has what has happened. Why has there
been an issue and why there is a wrong a
wrong answer? What is the part of the
process that failed? So we can it's very
hard to debug uh an LLM as it is. Even
though it's very simple, it's very hard
because it's practically black a black
box.
Given these limitations,
the community uh community the industry
our virus communities came up with the
idea of uh retrieval augmented
generation.
So what is retrieval augmented
generation?
The basic way as I said that an LM works
is that you give it a question or an
input.
The LLM uses it to generate an answer.
This is the the workflow very very
simply.
So ra retrieval generation says you know
what instead of doing that I'm going to
do something slightly different. Well
slightly quite different.
What am I going to do is
I'm going to get a question and before I
feed it to the large language model, I'm
going to use the question to retrieve
out of an existing database of documents
semantically
relevant information. So if I'm asking
for example um who is the president of
the United States and I have documents
that contain this information hopefully
in the retrieval step I will retrieve
those documents that might contain this
these keywords. So it's information it's
a search problem.
So we are retrieving usually top K
inter.
So we're retrieving K similar documents
and these documents are put together
with a question and are fed to the LLM
as context. So probably we're doing a qu
a question enrichment and we are saying
to the LLM you know what answer this
question based on this context
and that and that makes the LM hopefully
if it works if it works correctly to
exclude to ignore anything that it has
already been trained on and only focus
on what the context says
and what is the added value of DLM it's
language understanding it's language
processing so even if For example, the
the
uh the context contains the answer but
the answer is is differently phrased
maybe with synonym or with another uh
syntax then will be able to capture to
capture that capture this langu language
variation.
So
um as I said so yeah uh the knowledge is
retrieved it's used as a context and the
generator uh gets the answer.
So by that to some extent the
hallucination problem is tackled because
we give it context and if the external
knowledge is correct is accurate then
the chance of hallucination is is
significantly reduced. Furthermore, if
the answer we get is still wrong,
we can do some kind of debugging by
looking at what context has been
retrieved for the question. So for
example, if what we get from the
question is uh what we get as as context
is irrelevant to the question or perhaps
it is relevant but contains for example
something wrong, we can understand why
this has why the whole behavior is is
wrong.
Any
rag system practically consists of three
components in order to implement it. We
need an indexer. The indexer is a
mechanism to compress data into vectors
into embeddings and store them in a
database for our context. A retriever
which is going to get the input query
and retrieve the the relevant documents.
And finally a generator which is
practically a large language model that
uh will reason through the user squid in
the retrieve context to provide the
response. So all rag systems are
practically variations of of of
implement with different in different
ways these three components.
So as a as an example a bit more detail
on that what would be the process let's
say we have a large amount of documents
we start by splitting those documents
into chunks right and actually
how to uh how to split them is a science
on its own. It's a task on its own that
there's not a straightforward answer how
to best do that. But h each chunk we get
we generate an embedding for this and we
store it into a vector database. So this
is before we start using uh the system
and then when we have a query
um we retrieve the top k most similar
chunks from the database and we plug it
to the llm and we get a response.
Now this basic pattern is called basic
rug. This is the basic the very basic
pattern that we have. There are some
challenges there, right?
The first issue that might the first
problem that might happen with basic
rugg is we might not have very good
retrieval. So either we have low
precision, the retrieve context, the
retrieve documents are not really
relevant to the
to the question that we have because of
ambiguity can be because of other
things. H there is also a famous problem
called lost in the middle in the sense
that you might have
uh it might be that your answer is
perhaps I don't know in the 20th
document but you only get 10 so you will
never you are never able to really um h
get the context uh that you need or you
might have low recall so not all
relevant chunks are retrieved so you are
you are still missing important context
and but also you You can also have a
problem in in the in the way the
response is simulated. So you can have
hallucination also there. So the model
makes up an answer that is not in in the
context.
Okay. So given that
the knowledge graph community came and
said you know what we have an idea
instead of just feeding
textual documents in uh in a rag
architecture instead of indexing just
text let's see if we can use structural
information structure knowledge to as
contextual information for uh for an
so before I show how graph frag works.
Let's let me reiterate a bit about
knowledge graph. So
I guess as I said most of you know
already what knowledge graph is but the
definition I like to give is that
knowledge graphs are interconnected
entities and express semantics. They're
not really something really new but it's
rather a rebranding of of terms like
semantic networks knowledge bases from
the the 80s and and the 90s. So
if you have been designing database
schemas, taxonomies, ontologies etc. you
already know uh a lot of things about
them. Here's an example of a knowledge
graph. This is from uh Bloomberg.
I guess most of you know Bloomberg. It's
a financial data uh company and they
have been implementing knowledge graphs
for for various use cases and
uh this is a snapshot of of it and
practically you see that it's about
entities about companies about
industries people and the relations and
characteristics between these uh these
entities.
Another example that comes from the
domain that my my company operates on
tax kernel is ESCO. ESCO is a knowledge
graph that the European Union has
created and it's about professions and
skills and qualifications
organized hierarchy taxonomically and
linked to each other and it's used it's
meant to be used by the uh employment
agencies across across Europe
and of course there are a lot of public
knowledge graphs uh open source like
wikid data freebase freebase didn't
exist anymore. DBPD via etc. So there is
a lot of also free things that you can
experiment with.
Now
there is an important difference between
LMS and knowledge graphs and many and
I've got questions many times from from
clients from people that say okay why
can I just use an LLM instead of an
graph why should I use that right and
the main good summary of what is the
difference between LM and graph you can
see it in the following image so
knowledge graphs are about structural
explicit knowledge about symbolic
knowledge h it's about accuracy it's
about decisiveness and it's about
um
interpretability. So the main thing is
that with with a knowledge graph you see
what you get right you can easily
understand what it is about if it's if
if the knowledge graph is very well
documented on the other hand an LLM is
contains implicit knowledge that you
only get when you ask it you cannot
really go and see what is there because
it only has numbers embedded
and as we said big problem is
hallucination black box and it doesn't
necessarily have the domain knowledge
that that you want it to to
On the other hand, with a knowledge
graph on its own, you cannot really do
language understanding. You cannot
really do
and you can and you cannot do
generalization,
right? A knowledge graph and an ontology
can only be used for deductive
reasoning, right? So from things that
you know that are true and through rules
that you know that they are always true,
if the premise holds, you can infer
things. But if you try to generalize
things, if you try to guess, if you try
to do abduction or induction, this
doesn't work. This is where language
model excel.
So
there are practically three high level
usages of knowledge graphs at least that
that if we try to group them the way
we've seen being used in the industry.
So one big use case is semi data
digression. companies that organizations
that have information silos, data
warehouses, databases,
um, documents, etc. They want to be able
to access all those through a common
semantic layer. And this common semantic
layer is usually implemented by means of
a knowledge graph. And when you have
that that layer then you are able to do
better data analytics in data science
because instead of accessing uh
heterogeneous information you have a
layer that allows you to understand the
the data in a in a common way.
A third usage that we've seen a lot with
knowledge graphs is to be being used for
enhancing machine learning applications,
right? For um uh being used to uh make a
machine application more explainable,
more robust and practically covering the
the parts that they cannot work very
well with.
So this is what knowledge graphs are. So
what is knowledge graph rag? The idea is
very simple again like the previous very
similar to to to the to the common to
the basic ra that we've seen. We have
the question
and
before we feed it to the LLM we use the
question and we go and fetch information
from the knowledge graph instead of
documents
h and we use it to enhance the question.
So the question along with the relevant
information from the knowledgeless graph
is fed to the LLM and generates an
answer.
What's the advantage of that? There are
several advantages. Uh but the main
thing is that uh it's relationship and
context. So the fact that you can
consider a knowledge graph as a ideally
a a an accurate summary of a domain,
right? So you don't have all the padding
that you have in a in the and all the
variation that you have in a document.
You have succinct facts and statements
that if done correctly, they give you
all the context you need. So it's much
easier to to find the appropriate
information from from the knowledge
graph as opposed to try to find things
in a in a large pool of of documents. So
to some extent it is able to uh tackle
the issue of um of of of loss in the
middle right of of getting more uh
relevant information on top.
The moment there are there is no
standard way to implement graph rag uh
applications. There are some few common
uh patterns. However,
one pattern that uh we've seen uh that
I've seen I've seen it being implemented
both by uh the property graph community
by Neo4j and and such vendors but also
by some uh RDF vendors is the following.
You have your question and
you
access the graph to retrieve its schema.
So only the scheme of the graph the
classes the relations and the attributes
and you use this information to
transform the question to a structured
query. So for example, let's say that
you have a knowledge graph about movies
h and the movie has a class actor
then sorry and the graph has a class
movie and a class actor and a relation
has played in and then you ask you have
a question tell me who played in the
matrix which actor played in in matrix.
The way this would work in according to
this uh to this architectural pattern,
it would be that the question who played
in uh in matrix would be analyzed
through with the help of the knowledge
graph schema and and the content of
course and we transform into a query
something like select from um the graph
uh the entities that are actors and they
have play they're linked through through
the relation played in with the moving
the matrix, right? So,
of course, if
the translation between the natural
language question and the query is wrong
for any reason, either uh because there
is a typo, you know, a syntax error,
which happens a lot in in structural
queries or if simply the query is
different than the intended one, you're
you're going to get mistakes.
Another common erh pattern is called
knowledge graph enhanced question
answer. So what happens here?
>> Sorry just quickly question on the
previous slide.
>> Yeah. Um, if for example that knowledge
graph had the movies database in it and
instead of Keanu Reeves it had let's say
Michael Jackson in there then how would
you determine whether the knowledge
comes from the large language model
which says Kean Ruth for example but the
knowledge graph says Michael Jackson
which one would be seen as authoritative
>> the right
so the prioritization question is what
is in the knowledge graph.
>> Okay.
>> So if you ask it
if you ask it
in what movie
play the will be detected from here
>> if he exists
>> if he exists yes
>> if he doesn't exist I'm not sure what
will happen but most likely it won't
you're going to get a very wrong
question. So actually this pattern here
um it's effort I think is is it's going
to be correct in fewer cases than it's
going to be wrong. It depends a lot on
the quality. Actually the thing as
everything the the quality of graph rag
as we will see and this is why we're
here today depends a lot on the quality
of your knowledge graph both in terms of
schema and in terms of in terms of
content.
>> Yeah. a sort of followup question which
is if you are if you have got an output
that's off the back of a graph rank
query sorry can you
>> if you have a output that is off the
back of a graph rank query
how do you is there a is there other
tools available that will tell you this
part was generated by the part has been
like generated by query on the actual
graph view itself so you can kind of
distinguish you know this is the
>> yeah But in the implementation that I
have used when you run this when you run
this you can see how you how your
question has been translated to what
query.
>> So you can actually see the query if you
want to debug it and you can understand
if it's if it's correct or not.
>> You would call out tool basically.
So
in this pattern here now it's a bit
different here we have the input
question the input prompt which we use
some embedding mechanisms to create to
create vectors of that. So the question
is transformed into embeddings and then
we have also taken entities and
relations from the knowledge graph and
we have created vex for them as well and
we have put them in a vector database.
So for example we have taken all the
movies that we have and we have made
them as as as vectors. So what happens
is that um
based on the input we retrieve the
entities or rather index information
from uh the knowledge graph and h this
information is used as context sometimes
perhaps also by ex by extending that. So
imagine for example the following. Let's
say that we have
movies. We have again our movie graph
and for every movie we have a a a
summary a textual sum of what it has
right what it's about
and we decide and we want to create uh
and we have the question
I want to find movies that are about
romance or that are about horror movies.
The knowledge graph does not contain
designer explicitly but the information
is contained within the summary of the
movie. So if we have indexed the
entities the movies with their attribute
summary then we can retrieve we can take
this question and retrieve all the
movies that is the top five movies or
the top 10 movies that are about romance
that are about uh horror.
So it's very similar to the document
retrieval. It's just that instead of our
documents are entities and relations
that we have indexed in in a vector
database in a similar way that we do
with any kind of document.
Now
what are the challenges with graph rack?
There are many including like some
technical ones like comput requirements
performance scalability.
There's also still an issue of how we
evaluate rugg in general but also
knowledge graph rug but for me and for
many that I've seen is the con the
knowledge gra construction and
maintenance.
So
there are for companies and for
organizations that already have
knowledge graphs and they you know they
have already a habit of creating good
knowledge graphs curating them etc. to
implement graph rag is relatively
straightforward. There are tools there.
They have the graph. It works well. But
if it's the other way around, if you
have been working with LLMs and rag and
you someone tells you, you know what,
you should try a knowledge graph, it can
be very it can be seen like a very
daunting task to suddenly build a
knowledge graph out out of out of
nothing, right? Because it's not it's
not it's not an easy task. And why it's
not an easy task?
The thing is that as I mentioned in the
definition of a knowledge graph, a
knowledge graph
is meant to provide accurate meaning of
entity of entities and relations. This
meaning needs to be explicit which means
it needs to be understandable by both
humans and and systems and needs to be
shared. It needs to be agreed. Right?
The main difference I mean the main
difference in my opinion between a
knowledge graph and a typical database
is not so much the underlying model that
have a relational database versus a
graph database. Yeah, that that's that's
the difference. But the main thing is
that in the majority of the cases you
build a database for a single
application but you build a knowledge
graph for many applications and you
build a knowledge graph to share meaning
and to close sematic gaps. Something
that you never do with you rarely do
with a single database or even with a
single data warehouse. So
it's very easy to build a knowledge
graph but to build a knowledge graph
that uh is able to reconcile
the the interpretation of a domain the
interpretation of data in a large scale
can be very hard.
And why is it hard?
Because of these things here. Because of
real world communication and language,
because of ambiguity, we have all these
terms that can mean multiple things and
and the knowledge graph needs to be able
to capture this ambiguity.
The flip side of ambiguity, which is
diversity and variety, we can express
the same thing in so many different
ways.
Vagueness, which is a very important
thing and something that in my opinion
the semantic community has been hiding
for many years from it. the fact that
there are so many concepts and
predicates for which it's impossible to
define an objective truth an objective
truth criteria right what is large what
is average what is rich right there is
there are no universal definitions about
these concepts there are only context
specific and subjective definitions for
which means that the more again you want
to have agreement the the more difficult
it is you also have sematic change
meaning changes over time which means
that even if you manage to build a
knowledge graph in five months, in a
year etc. your job doesn't stop there.
You need to continue maintaining, you
need to continue evolving it, especially
if you if you are in a very volatile
domain, right? In a very dynamic domain.
And finally, we have what I call bad or
even just different development
practices, right?
We have property graphs. We have RDF
already the representation layer. We
have if you try to model the same piece
of information, there are so many
patterns and different ways to represent
the same information. For example, let's
say that I want to uh model the location
of a film, the location where a film was
produced. Do I make it an attribute or a
relation? Both are fine. But if in your
model it's a it's a relation in my model
it's an attribute there's no
interoperability there right
and unfortunately we've seen different
development practices even within the
same organizations especially large ones
I've heard people telling me you know
what we have this team that has built a
property graph with their own method and
we have another team in the same
organization that has built a native
graph using other things they it's not
that one of them is correct and the
other one is wrong but they if they
don't speak the same language you can
imagine how how hard it's going to be to
to work together
so the message is this s money is going
to be hard to stay
so
the question that now arises is and I
should get a lot
but can I just use an LM with an LS
graph
Right. Yeah. Yeah. I don't have a
knowledge graph, but you know what? This
ventor told me the other day that no
worries. Take your data, take the
documents that you seen and instead of
creating vector embeddings and putting
them in a vector database, run them
through run them through an LLM and
create a knowledge graph. And here you
are. You have graph rag. Right? Sounds
good. Too good to be true, right?
What about
you?
It's just extracting information. You
don't have a source to check.
>> No, you don't. Indeed, you don't. No,
you don't have transparency. The only
thing is that as soon as you extract
information, you put it in knowledge
graph, you can see, you can read it.
It's words now. which means that this
structure then you can show it to your
applications and to your users think
this is my transparency.
So you go as a step it kind of makes
sense to say that uh yeah with the
documents and with the embeddings
there's no transparency at all by having
it as a knowledge graph then I can
provide some explanations. The main
issue is what is the quality of the of
the knowledge graph that you get. So
this is what we want I want you to to
show now.
So
since when LLM started there was the
community of knowledge engineers and
respective developers started thinking
okay can we use LLM to help us with our
task right uh are they going to replace
us as knowledge engineers am I needed do
I need to learn RDF or they can use LLM
to create RDF for me right do we need
linguist do we need knowledge engineers
so basically the research that
We did um I came up with three ways
three let's say different roles that an
LLM can play when we build a knowledge
graph. The first role is to use the LM
as a knowledge provider as a domain
expert. Right? In the same way that you
would ask a domain expert tell me for
example what skills a data scientist to
have in order to populate my knowledge
graph about occupations and skills. I
would ask an LLM for that. The second
role is to use DLM for knowledge
engineering. So in the same way that I
can ask an LLM to create for me a Python
method to sort a list or to write code,
I could ask it to provide me RDF
representation or new for representation
to to be able to answer the following
competency questions or the following
requirements which is something
typically knowledge engineers do. And
finally, the third role is knowledge
mining extraction, right? Can I use uh
an LLM to extract entities and relations
and attributes to put it in the
knowledge graph to populate it instead
of doing it manually, which is awfully
expensive and and and very and
non-scalable at all.
So let's let's see in detail each of
these roles.
First, aliens as knowledge providers.
For some things, an alien will give you
correct answers. If I ask you what are
the um
what are
the EU countries, the European Union
countries, it gives you 27 countries
that that are correct.
But when I asked for example to give me
a list of books that have been published
by O'Reilly about that engineering,
problem starts. And the problems have to
do with the fact that we with what we've
seen already what we talk already
hallucinations.
So the first book is an actual book
design application by Martin Clean. This
is a real book. This is the correct
author. This is the correct publisher
etc. The second book that engineering
teams by Jesse Anderson
does not really exist. What exist is a
book by Jesse Anderson called data
teams. So the title is different and
there is another publisher and the same
applies for three books. So this is what
hallucination looks in action, right?
Which means that
an LLM might generate facts that were
never in it training data nor can be
deductively inferred. Right? There's no
rule that makes so
there's another interesting thing
inconsistency.
I was playing with an I was playing with
and I wanted to see how well it sensor
a very important relation in Yes.
>> Sorry. Um people online um
the laptop keeps kind of coming in and
out.
>> Ah okay. Sorry.
>> Sorry about that.
>> No no it's okay. Thank you. My mistake.
Okay. So I was playing with synonym. I
was trying to see if it can provide
synonyms.
And I came up to this
I asked I gave a question saying okay
you're the main expert information
technology give me some synonyms for
data scientist
it gave me 10 terms we can agree or
disagree about this I think the majority
are wrong but that's not the most
important thing the most important thing
is that when I ask it to give me
some synony
when I took
one of them and data scientist and I
rephrase the question and I asked it are
these two synonyms
the expectation would be that it would
say yes because previously
it said they are yet here it found a
difference and they say no they're not
so this is something that hopefully most
humans will not do right so there's not
internal consistency something that we
want from a knowledge graph right
uh which means that really as knowledge
providers LLMs are very unreliable. They
may contain factual and domain knowledge
might be there but it is not easily
retrievable in an accurate and reliable
way
and usually the advice I give to my team
and to others that when they use this is
always corroborate
what you get from the LLM with
additional data sources right additional
evidence
now let's go to LM as knowledge
engineers
Here's an example where we ask the LLM
to take two competency questions as I
like to call them. So competency
questions are questions that our
knowledge graph is supposed to be able
to answer in a structured way by means
of so questions that we can express with
the corresponding query language that a
knowledge graph is implemented with. So
if it's RDF, we should be able to
express uh the question by means of
spark code. If it's neo forj, we should
be able to do it by cipher. So I run
this and it actually gave me a pretty
good model. It's correct. I'm not going
to go into details, but but it's it's
pretty accurate
and it also worked quite well in Neo
forj as well for the same thing. But
when I gave it a more tricky example
and the example is that I have the
following situation. A company can have
clients and there are two types of
clients individuals and organizations.
This is actually an example that usually
also human knowledge engineers uh do as
a mistake. So what happened here? It
modeled
organization as a class and it made
organization a subclass of client
and it also made individual as a
subclass of client. So practically this
model tells us that all all
organizations are clients as well
because this is these are the semantics
of the surplus relation which is
obviously wrong not all organization is
wrong. Perhaps what actually we meant
here and an experienced knowledge
engineer would see is that when I say
individual and organization, I don't
mean any individual and any
organization. I I mean individual
clients and organizational clients. So a
proper model from an experienced
knowledge engineer would be I have
client and I have as a subclass
individual client and organizational
client. So NLM cannot do this.
They don't really understand the
semantics the formal semantics of
subclass in all or in or even proper
naming.
Here's another example. How many of you
know SCOS?
Yes. So SCOS is a same is a is a is a
framework is a model where you have
concepts and you have a broader narrow
relations between concepts and the
broader narrow relation includes three
three different types of relations
subsumption. So the meaning is included
in the meaning. So for example machine
learning supervised machine learning it
includes the part of relation and it
includes the the instance of relation.
You can have for example um country
Greece, country UK, all three together
under broader narrower. So when I ask it
to give me in course the following
information Greece is a location, Athens
is in Greece. Situ Acropolis is in
Athens,
it gives me a correct model.
But when I do the same in all
where in all we don't have the broader
narrow relation as it is we have
subasses usually it goes and models
Greece and Athens as classes which is
obviously wrong because these are
individual entities they are named
entities and they make a subclass one of
the other which is plainly wrong.
So in this example, VLM does not seem to
graph the former semicass neither to
distinguish between class and
individuals which is again something
that
h is critical
in
the nclass setting
especially we you don't because the
thing is if you if the subclass relation
is wrong because subclass in knowledge
graph is a is a relation that has a very
basic inference rule right all The
instances of a subclass are also
instances automatically of a superclass.
Which means that for every subclass
relation that is wrong,
you risk of producing thousands of
statements that are simply wrong.
So an LLM can help with semantic
modeling, but it does not seem to
actually understand the semantics of the
modeling language. It's
again from what I've seen so far. I
don't know what will happen in the
future. I only see paring
it has learned from examples from good
and bad examples because there are also
very bad examples on the web of ontolo
of wrong ontology. So it's not that made
up this situations. I've seen ontologies
by humans uh human developers that
contain wrong subasses. So DLM you know
it's like we we are bad teachers of it's
not like it's the data again it's the B
the data have
now LLM has knowledge miners the third
thing
before LLM if you wanted to build an
entity extraction system for example or
relation extraction
um you needed to either create
extraction rules usually with NLP I
don't know how many of you worked in
this field, right? Take text and create
take a sentence, parse it with part of
speech, create patterns to extract
entities and relations or later on with
machine learning you created um a lot of
uh positive and negative examples and
you train some machine learning system
to to do the extraction. LLMs have made
this slightly easier. So with an LLM we
can do three things before we sorry
uh before we go and create an advanced
model. First we can simply prop the LLM
with a description of the knowled task
of of the extraction task. No examples,
no nothing. Just we try to take
advantage of what the LM already knows,
what patterns it already knows,
what reasoning pattern already knows.
The second approach is to do what we
call fusot learning fus extraction. This
is when along with the instruction with
the guidelines we also give it some
examples of good and bad extractions.
This is how the the result should be.
And if you think about it, it's also the
way knowledge engineers define concepts.
When you want to define for example a
meaning of a class, what is a person?
What is a customer? How do we do that?
For a class we define the crit the
necessary and uh the necessary criteria
according to which an entity is a member
of that class and also we give examples
and counter examples. So since something
similar applies here
a more advanced approach that it makes
sense when the other things have failed
is to do fine-tuning. So you take an
offthe-shelf LLM, you create training
data uh of with examples input output
examples of the exception task and you
train a bit more the the LLM in order to
make it specific for you to optimize it
for for your extraction task.
And of course this is more expensive as
a task than the other two, right?
Let's see some zero shot extraction in
in action and see what can go wrong.
I took a film review. This is from the
godfather. We're going to use it as well
later on for uh for graph building. So
we have the review which is the text and
we're asking the LLM to identify all the
actor film director and character
entities that are mentioned in in the
text. So we're practically asking to do
entity extraction for us. Right? By
giving it the classes, by giving the
entity types that we want,
the LM gives a quite convincing answer
which seems seems correct with a minor
cuts.
I don't know if you can see it,
but
um when I look at that first I like I
saw I said okay makes sense. But if you
notice, the system tells me that there
is a film, The Godfather Part Two.
The text never says The Godfather Part
Two. Only says part two.
So how does the LLM know that there is a
movie called The Godfather Part Two?
I mean,
the idea is to use only the information
in the text, no external knowledge.
So in order to corroborate that to see
to to verify if this is the case I
change the prompt and I ask it consider
only what's in the text and what you
know already and then and only then
it gave part two which is not optimal
but it's better than before at least
it's more accurate
with that.
Here's another example. In order to
further test this I did the following. I
write a custom
review a custom sentence which says the
script of the godfather written by
Francis Ford Copola narrates the change
of Michael Leon etc etc and then I ask
you to find me film director and
character and what do you see here the
director Copola
how does the LLM know that copa is a
director the text doesn't say that so it
uses its own knowledge from it training
And you can further verify this by
replacing
Fort Copa with a random name John Doe.
So now there's no director here.
So what does this tell us?
The LLM will com even with extraction
will combine prior factual knowledge
with information mentioned in the text
and it it needs quite a lot of effort to
make it work only on the text. Sometimes
that's desirable because sometimes with
the prior knowledge you may get
something that is less ambiguous and uh
more consistent.
But if the knowledge that it has for the
domain that you are looking for is
wrong, you are risking of getting wrong
information that is not in your in in
the documents in in in the text from
which you do the extraction.
Right?
And something else
LLMs are hailed, you know, are praised
for their language understanding
capabilities and indeed they have shown
to to be able to understand language,
understand in quotes always better than
typical systems. However, they still
have uh blind spots. Here's an example.
This is an example where we use the LLM
to do zero shot relation extraction. So
we have the same text as before and we
say in the text below what is the
relation between John do one entity and
the godfather. The possible relations
are acted in directed wrote and unknown.
And correctly the system says the
relation between and the godfather is
wrote that's fine.
But then I go and change this
from wrote to rumored to have been
written by.
Now semantically this is different.
This is a rumor. Doesn't mean that it's
true. So the our ideal system should not
say that this is a a right a relation.
Yet the system tells us that the
relation is still wrote.
And here you can see in action the
nonsensical explanations that I
mentioned earlier. It says that yeah it
is rumored to have written therefore the
relation is wrote which is crazy right?
Doesn't make sense.
And the only way I managed to make this
work at least for this example is by
doing what we call few short learning.
So in order to try and teach the LLM the
notion of uncertainty and hedging in in
natural language I gave it examples
slightly different. So in the text in
the second example Bill do might have
written might have written to story the
lesson is not wrong it's a no.
This is a in action an example of where
we give some few examples and by which
we can improve improve the LLM. So
in summary for for this part despite
their advanced language understanding
capabilities can still struggle with
certain linguistic and semantic
phenomena. I've seen struggling with
negation even though it's supposed to
work well with f with tense variation
future tense versus past tense etc. with
more advanced things like
presuppositions implications you know
these things. So
the they need to be very carefully
evaluated. So an LLM can be a decent
knowledge minor.
We use it a lot in in my in in my team.
But always in order for this to work
first they need to have very clear and
detailed instructions and examples and
also thoroughly evaluated. And that's a
reason as we will see later on that
because of this trusting
a process a tool that tells you you know
throw everything throw documents that
you have and get one knowledge graph out
of that and and expecting it to be
correct right it's it's very far from
what kind it's very far from feasible
okay are there any questions so Before
I go and show you some demo.
Yes.
knowledge.
>> Oh, we can do that as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, I didn't mention
that. Indeed. Um, you can do you can do
it also for the knowledge for the
knowledge engineer.
You can create pairs of questions with
queries
trying to teach uh the LLM to uh
understand better the particular query
language that that you have. Yeah.
>> And actually I think
the new 4J people have been
experimenting with with this kind of
thing. I don't know the results. It's
not an easy process but uh it's
definitely something that you can do.
Yes.
Okay.
So
um let me
So in order to
further see what we've discussed
already, I'm going to show you now uh a
graph that I built this morning actually
uh automatically using the new 4J graph
builder. This is not an advertising
nor an accusation. is just uh
I think a very representative example of
of uh capabilities.
So before of that
let me are you all aware is there is
there anyone who has never used or seen
neo forj
are you all aware of the of the property
graph model? Okay cool.
Okay. So,
okay. So what I did this morning was
that I created an instance of of a new
4J database in in a uh graph DB in in an
instance of of 4J database and then
through this user interface
I uploaded a document with a film review
for the moon godfather.
It's like I think maybe 8 800 words or
something. So a very a very small uh
sample. It was actually a review by
Roger Edbert. I don't know if you know
he he was a f a famous a famous film
critic. So
uh through this user interface I
uploaded the the document and uh I press
generated the graph and then I got a
graph which I'm going to show you right
now.
Okay.
So what do we have here?
All these are the relations
that the LLM because this is an LLM
based method identified in in the in the
film view text. So we have relations
like dispatch does embodies characters
features gives warning. They seem
legitimate right? What you see in in
color are the node labels and in
property graphs as you probably know
node labels are mainly used as
informally rather as classes as as
entity types. They don't have formal
semantics. In theory you can put any
label you like. there is not a
restriction but in in the majority of
the of the cases you use um you use
labels as a way to uh represent the uh
to express the type of the entity that
the node the node is about. So
what we have here and so there are very
there are several
interesting things that that we see
here. So
let's see some examples.
The first thing is um
you did things like this has husband
which is a nice relation and then you
have the entities his sister and her
husband
which by the way are supposed to be
entities of type person.
So obviously here DM doesn't really
understand what a person is.
or at least what we mean as a person
because the whole goal usually as a
person we mean individual people right
with a name etc. So obviously
we have this this problem here
another thing
is this we have Michael and we have
Tom Hagen does not trust this is
relatively okay though
Michael is rather an illdefined
name maybe top hygien is more specific
because it's more identifiable. But
again, if you if you were a human and
you would write the entity Michael, it's
not really Michael. It's Michael Corleon
in this case, right? So the the the
problem here is understandability. Who
is Michael here? Which entity are we
talking about?
Another
example is this one. The godfather has
creator Copola. Who is Copa? Yes.
>> Just a question which is when you built
this your prompt to
11.
>> No.
That's why this is just of course
this was an example where you just put
text and it has some predefined prompts
obviously
>> and this is my yeah what I'm trying to
show here is not that this is a a bad
tool for what it has been designed for
what has been the way it has been
designed probably does already quite
good things but it's it's the thing is
that you cannot just use it as it is
because you have uh issues like that and
actually
uh so you get a lot of nonsensical
things.
Here's another example of a completely
stupid thing. Ah Minor
composed for Fellini films. Okay. Um
this is another example. Don't VTO has
wife, Vito's wife.
So issues here are and we've seen it a
lot is
we have indefined entities. We have
entities that should be synonyms that
they are not. So you see copa somewhere
and there's another node called Francis
for Copa. This ideal should be the same
the same entity right vice versa
you have copa as an entity copa can mean
especially in the context of godfather
you can have sophia copa who's also an
actor there are all all types of
entities. Yes I'm going to summarize
this this this in a bit. So,
so yeah, the question now is that we got
this and
we got this. The question is what do we
do with that?
There are many um
there are system I don't have you ever
have you heard of Microsoft rag the
system of Microsoft graph rag they do
something similar well not exactly the
same I don't know what else they use but
they hide the the they the intermediate
knowledge graph you just start with
documents they create the knowledge
graph and then they just fade it to to
rug application so what I'm trying to
show here is that from a flow from
implementation flow perspective Yes, you
can use input documents to create a
knowledge graph like that. But obviously
you don't want to put that or something
like that in your graph or rag
application. First you need to fix the
quality right how many steps etc.
Ideally in my in my in my opinion
uh you we should have tried to build the
graph properly but let's say that you
don't have enough resources right you
need something fast maybe okay this can
help this this these tools can help uh
but
they need
to be scrutinized and the output needs
to be carefully h fixed carefully
improved
So what I want to talk now is okay we
have a knowledge graph that we either
have built by any means or you know we
have taken it from someone else. How do
we assess it quality? How do we think in
terms of quality?
Actually I have a question those of you
someone of you who building knowledge
graph how do you typically measure
quality? What are some dimensions that
you measure the quality of your
knowledge graph against?
Yeah,
>> we've had people asking asking questions
>> and
you ask questions, you get answers and
then what do you what do you measure?
What do you evaluate?
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Something else. Yeah.
unit tests
>> which will come with
check validation checks practically what
>> well
>> accuracy or
>> so like basic basic check validation in
terms of this is what you know can only
have one of these instances connected to
it expect multiple ones here up to then
using foundation kind of like writing
structured queries that be like when
this query executes then expect this
result to come back out
>> and then you
produce that like kind of shack
validation report a bit like unit test
but like unit test
>> exactly yeah test s validation that's
actually good for consistency we'll see
that as a dimensions about having
sematically consistent indeed so the
main dimensions that we've seen In in
knowledge graphs the the first and
foremost of course semantic accuracy how
the degree to which the semantic
assertions of a knowledge graph are
asserted to be true right and are
accepted to be true ar
wrong statements and why a knowledge
graph might be inaccurate there are so
many reasons first the data sources from
which it has been created can contain
mistakes right data if it's data or even
people even domain experts do mistakes.
Second, the population methods and
pipelines can also be inaccurate. We've
seen that in the case with LLMs, right?
And can also happen with other knowledge
extraction and information extraction
methods.
There are also many cases where the
modeling elements of the
of the the of the modeling framework and
language we use h has been
misunderstood. One of my favorite not my
favorite one of the main things that I
have seen happening a lot is the misuse
of RDFS domain and range. Any anyone
aware of this?
Do you know what are the semantics of
RDFS domain and range? These are
inference rules yet they used as
constraints.
The people expect that when they say
that um how to say a movie has actor and
actor right and the has actor has domain
movie and range actor then if I put two
different entities through the same
relation I should get a warning I should
get an error this doesn't happen this is
where suckle comes into place as as Tony
said right and this is a very typical
mistake that has been done and uh by by
engineers by semantic models etc.
Then you can have simply lack of domain
knowledge and expertise. You can also
have biases right
>> I don't know but when I see that
the advantage you know claims that the
advantage of a knowledge graph is that
it's bias free compared to machine
learning for me that doesn't make sense
a knowledge graph will contain the bias
of its creators and of the data it has
been created with even when I take a
modeling decision and decide even the
way I name things contains bias good
bias or bad bias
It's another thing but it contains back
and of course vagueness. The more vague
the more subjective you have knowledge
the more the higher the higher is the
likelihood that something that I believe
is true is not going to be true for you.
Right? If I
do a poll here and ask you tell me the
10 essential skills for data scientist
profession. I will get how many here? 30
different answers, 30 different
rankings. And it's not that you will be
wrong, I will be right. You know, you
will be wrong and right. All of you will
be correct because it's there's
objectivity, there's context dependence
and that's inevitable.
Then the second another dimension is
completeness. Do we have all the
knowledge that we want for our domain in
the knowledge graph?
And that's
a very difficult dimension to measure
because there is rarely a golden truth
right a golden standard for that. So
usually what we do here is we try to to
guess to try to to guess to to estimate
that for example if I have a movie graph
and for every movie I have only one
actor then most likely it's not complete
right but if I have five or six actors I
don't really know if I have all all the
actors that they should be there for
instance
why a knowledge graph may be complete
the domain may be too large and very
high conceptual complexity.
In many cases, there is no uh available
or ineffective there is in effective
knowledge mining tooling and we've seen
that a lot in uh before the L1 before
the machine learning era where most
population of of of ontology and
knowledge graph was a manual task.
uh sometimes we don't have I've seen
organizations saying we want to build an
ontology or a knowledge graph about this
domain but they don't have the data
right they don't have the raw data to to
use them so they only can use domain
experts who are very expensive right
vagueness can also um
create an issue with completeness
because when the the higher is the
degree of the higher the degree of
vagueness is the more reward work you
need to do in order to achieve
consensus, in order to achieve
agreement, which means that you delay
the completion of the knowledge graph.
And finally, high domain volatility and
dynamics, right? If you have a very high
vol
to to to catch it.
Another dimension is consistency
is the degree to which a knowledge graph
is free of logical or semantic
contradictions. It's what we saw with
the asking the LM about synonyms. Right?
We want the knowledge graph to be
consistent. We don't want to have
contradictory things and some and to to
to a large extent as we will see
consistency is h satisfied is is
enforced by means of constraints by
means of subtle validation but also by
means of of other of other rules which
when they are violated something is
wrong
and that's usually the reason why we
have h inconsistency in knowledge graph.
Either it's very hard to express a
constraint rules or
the model framework we employ does not
inherently support them.
Another interesting quality dimension is
conciseness.
Conciseness is the degree to which the
knowledge graph does not contain
redundant elements. One type of
redundancy is when you have two entities
for the same for the same two different
entities for the same entity. So things
that should be seen on it. Another one
is modeling the same information as in
two different ways. You can have the
same characteristic of an entity for
example both as a as an attribute as a
property and as a relation for example
right we've seen that I've seen that at
least happening a lot. And why does it
happen? When does it happen? It happens
in many cases when you have in
distributed and decentralized modeling
situations when you have different teams
working on the same graph and each of
them and they don't really coordinate on
the decisions and someone says you know
I need this characteristic I'm just
going to add this property here maybe
with a slightly different name right
but can also be that and I've seen that
happening that you want to optimize the
noise for different applications at the
same time and these applications may
have contradicting requirements.
Uh and someone says you know what we
don't have time to build another version
let's just add this and we say that this
particular characteristic or this
particular piece of information is going
to be used for this application and only
for that happens. So a lot of legacy
elements a lot of of temporary elements.
Finally
relevancy that's perhaps the most
important thing and that's I think the
main issue with how you build your
knowledge graph when you just say take
this data and build the knowledge map.
Sorry for for my watching.
A knowledge graph may be perfect, may be
fully correct, consistent, accurate,
complete, but it may not have it may be
missing information that is critical for
the task at hand.
For example,
if you use a knowledge graph to perform
entity disambiguation,
you want it for every term that it
contains to have ideally all the
possible meanings of that of that term
of of all the terms. For every meaning
that you miss and might appear in in the
data that you want to analyze,
you're blind. You don't know that this
meaning exists. So you're not able to
disambiguate.
So you can have a nice domain graph can
be completely accurate but it may not be
fitting for that particular task.
Erh I've also seen a lot having a
knowledge graph that contains the
relevant information for the task but in
a way that is either technically
incompatible or not easily accessible.
And most of the cases it's because the
knowledge graphs have been developed
without having considered the
application requirements. And this is
what from my experience the main problem
of reusing public knowledge graphs
when I I remember many years ago I tried
to to use DBPedia. DBP is a knowledge
graph out of Wikipedia to use knowledge
of from DBPedia for the our knowledge
graph in text. So trying to find
occupations etc. There was information
about occupation skills but there was no
way to distinguish it based on the
schema that it had and also based on the
quality from the other knowledge. So
practically we couldn't use that source
unfortunately right it's not that it was
a bad graph it was not just not relevant
to what uh we wanted to do
another important dimension and this I
think dimension is also important for
the lime is understandability
this is the is with which a human can
understand the knowledge graph elements
without misunderstanding or doubting
their meaning
there are many
in knowledge is you can see a relation
where you can see an entity name as we
saw Mikey for example there right and
you have no idea what this is about
unless you try to see the whole context
but when you see it in isolation
uh you don't understand what it is about
especially if you're not an expert of
the domain
you have names of entities that are just
single words you know or that they are
highly ambiguous the names themselves or
they're vague
and an an abst ract. So imagine this
when a human cannot understand what
an entity or a relation is about, how
can we expect an LLM to do the same
thing, right? Um
yeah, so a descendability is important I
would say before the era of LLMs mainly
for humans which is important but also
nowadays for
uh for LLMs.
So why knowledge graph may be difficult
to understand? It's usually because we
have bad or inadequate descriptions and
names and they use micro element names
obscure actions. The majority of the
cases no human readable definitions
actually there was this I think like
like a religious zeal saying that you
know what to to properly describe an
entity through logic you need to just
relate it with other entities and that's
enough. The thing is that there are many
things that you can express for an
entity just by using natural language
definitions in many cases that you can
never capture formally with um with
relations
and of course many cases there are
biases and assumptions that are never
documented.
I remember
in my first years in a text journal I
was looking at the knowledge graph and I
was like why does that that doesn't make
sense that's wrong
I need to fix that and then someone came
no we call it like that because of that
and that if you change it it will break
this and this and this so there are
there can be valid reasons why something
is has a particular name or has a
particular relation etc. But it's very
rare that that's what I have seen for
this to be documented somewhere and that
um makes understandability quite quite
hard.
So
managing and controlling the quality of
a knowledge graph is not something that
you do
in one step. Right?
When you build and you maintain
knowledge graphics, you need to do it in
a life cycle form consistently. You
start with selecting the quality
dimensions. What do I care to measure?
Do I care about accuracy? Do I care
about completeness? Do I care about
consistency?
What is the relative importance? For
instance, there is a standard tradeoff
between accuracy and completeness. In
the same way that in machine learning,
you have the trade-off between precision
and recall. Right?
If I want higher completeness, I can
just loosen the controls of my h of my
extraction methods. Add things in there.
There will be wrong things, but there
will be also correct things. So,
completeness is magically improved.
The second step is to define metrics,
quality metrics. How do I measure
accuracy? How do I measure consistency?
And most importantly, how do I interpret
the results? Right? I think as in many
things telling me that you have a
knowledge graph that is 80% accurate
doesn't tell me a thing. I need to
understand if this 20% is important for
my business or not right or for the
applications that it uses it. It might
be that in some aspects it is highly
accurate in some other subdomains or
some other particular relation is very
bad which means that it's it's not so so
usable there.
A third step is to define and implement
quality signals.
Signals are
very often confused for um for metrics,
but it's not really the same. So signals
are um things that when you see they
grow the suspicion that something is
wrong,
but they don't necessarily um reflect
the the quality. A fourth step is to
define diagnostic and fixing actions.
Okay, we see that something is wrong.
Why is it wrong? We've seen that we have
for example a lot of bad synonyms. What
is the problem? Is the problem the data
source that we use? Is the problem the
methods that we use? Right? So, so to go
back and do root root anal root root
cause analysis stuff and finally we need
to operationalize that determine who and
when is going to be monitoring the
quality and how should they should they
act.
Now detecting quality problems
as a summary of what I said before some
common problems that we see a lot in
automatically extracted knowledge graphs
are the following.
first synonyms
in my experience at least correct me if
I'm if I'm wrong or you have a different
experience the majority of the automatic
knowledge graph extraction meth methods
and tools do a very bad job bad job
identifying synonyms together. So either
we have the same entity and concepts
that should not be the same or vice
versa.
classes subclasses is also a big pain a
big problem as as we saw in the case of
LLM with the case of acropolis etc right
most of the current tooling is not able
to distinguish between what a class is
what an individual is and when one
should be model as the other and this is
also and this is a problem also for
humans in many cases because there are
cases where you have concepts and
entities that could be equally modeled
as individuals and and classes at the
same time.
Naming naming is an art,
right? And good good knowledge engineers
uh give a lot of um focus a lot of
effort into properly naming things at
least at the level of of of the schema
the level of the ontology rather than
all the entities that exist in the nor.
So to have very good and very well
definfined names of classes of relations
and attributes is very important because
that will guide and will uh influence
the the population and and the other
steps of the knowledge graph development
inconsistencies.
Inconsistencies in knowledge graph
extraction usually is an afterthought
right we saw that in the case with the
LLM now so very few tools are have
already been using perhaps subtle or
other
how to call them or other
consistency rules most of the cases we
just get things
detect relations and entities and that's
it and finally finally Yeah, we have in
many cases inaccurate statements due to
still inadequate language understanding,
negation, tense variation, uncertainty,
presupposition, indications and many
other linguistic and and semantic
phenomena
can can make it very that we find in
natural language can make it very hard
to can produce a lot of incorrect uh
statements.
Now
obviously um
all these need to be tackled and there
are many methods by which they can be
tackled. We don't have the time or the
space here to
uh to talk in detail about this. Usually
in the class that I teach the course
that I teach we do uh you um try a lot
of huristics etc. But as a summary I'd
like to tell you the following. So
usually inadequate and incorrect
scenario detection is tackled by when
you have a knowledge graph by trying to
find semantic by using semantic
similarity measures. So you have a
knowledge graph with entities and
relations. You can apply semantic
similarity measures to find distinct
entities that have a high similarity. So
most likely this should be correct. This
this should be the same. And vice versa
if you have highly dissimilar synonyms
then most likely these are not this
should not be synonyms at all. Right?
For subasses,
the main huristic that we use is I mean
one technique would be to try to find to
see if named entities have been wrongly
identified as classes. But generally the
main thing is to see if the subclass
definition is is violated. Right? The
logical definition of subclass is that
again any instance of a subclass is also
an instance of a superass.
uh and I have we have implemented
techniques where we use LLMs I will show
later to actually verify that this is
correct or not. For element names, there
are huristics that you can use like be
very weary, be very careful of, you
know, very short names. Single word
entity names are usually very abstract,
very very ambiguous, right? Uh in in
most domains and look for names that can
have multiple meanings according
dictionary or other knowledge source
for inconsistencies. For inconsistency,
I think the best way is what Tony said,
use circle or any in general
um apply consistency rules, define
consistency rules based on the knowledge
of your domain.
And finally, for inaccurate statements,
the main thing you can do is use
additional data sources, knowledge to
corroborate what you get, right? instead
of trusting one method in one source.
For many of these tasks, simply
heristics will uncover considerable
amount of errors.
I have um
yeah simpuristics like no fancy machine
learning, no nothing. But we al we have
also seen that for more nuance and
difficult task a zero or few short LLM
as a judge approach
can work. What do I mean by that? This
is the case LLM as a judge is an
approach where you don't use an LLM to
produce you something but you use an LLM
to check the output of another LLM of of
another system. And
there you don't so much care about the
accuracy of the judge. care whether it
can unear it can it can uncover errors
because your goal is to fix errors it's
not to to measure to to measure the
quality and we have seen that for tasks
that uh when you do it in an extraction
mode an might not work so well when you
flip when you flip it and you use it to
say okay is this correct or not you can
get quite quite good results ambiguity
for example um couple of months ago in
my team we said okay we had we needed to
find a priority we had find ambiguity of
certain names of certain names that we
have in ourology so we took an LLM and
we asked it for particular entity names
in context whether this is the correct
meaning and it was quite accurate saying
that you know what in this context this
is not the intended meaning that you
have there so we managed to find a lot
of bad seeds like a lot of highly
ambiguous and and fix them
in all cases is
having
a well- definfined schema of your design
knowledge graph is of utmost importance
and a mistake that I've seen many doing
is starting building the knowledge graph
without uh giving adequate
uh focus on the schema. schema I mean
the classes and the relations right. Um
for example uh I was working in a
project and and they were telling me uh
okay we need to expand the knowledge
graph with a relation between
professions and skills. I'm like okay
what are the semantics of this relation?
Ah skills that are related to profession
this is not enough. What does it mean?
Um does it mean for example skills that
a profession needs to have in order
someone needs to have in order to apply
this profession? Should they be
obligatory like for example you know
legally based or just what happens in
the industry? Should they should they be
reflect
what the employers want
or what the employees what the people
have? Right? Because I might have as an
ontologist skills
that nobody's using anymore in the
industry, which means I have those as a
skill, but I consider them essential,
but someone else might not want them. So
if we don't have this criteria well
defined then we are not going to be able
to check the quality and we're also not
going to be able to to create meaningful
and accurate uh knowledge extraction and
knowledge population methods.
Okay,
wrapping up
three takeaways from this master class
if nothing else.
Knowledge graph rag is a worthwhile
approach to grounding large language
model with factual domain knowledge. So
um
an LLM on its own is can be good but it
really needs grounding and knowledge
grass can really help. Llms can help
with knowledge graph construction. So if
you don't already have a good knowledge
graph as we saw we can use it we can use
LMS to help us with the the development
but be careful that the resulting
quality might be not the best might be
inadequate right so don't we don't trust
them as they are so and it's always
imperative when we build knowledge graph
rag applications to assess the quality
of a knowledge graph before using it as
part of of a rag application it's not
only the LLM it's also the knowledge
graph very very important.
Okay, thank you very much. Any
questions?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh no, is this recording? No, I cannot
set the slide. Sorry.
Yeah,
>> I think it will be made available as
part of the program.
>> You should be able I think to see the
recording. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Another question. Yeah.
>> Let's assume we have the perfect
knowledge graph and especially for the
extraction part where we had the most
let's say promise in this whole thing.
Um if I have this perfectly done. And
how do I give it to the
what do I do to get it to uh the the LLM
to work properly on that thing? Because
my thought process is I have the perfect
description in my classes. I really
spend my time on this
>> and have everything semantically nicely
defined. that doesn't mean it in in the
text that it gets that it understands
what I because there's no similarity in
this with with my description or if I
use the wrong description it embeds my
description and uh tries to match
something there but it's not clear. So
do I have to inside my ontology and my
my schema do I have to put in the
examples also in there that to generate
this and then go uh few short and
fine-tuning and then embed my or bring
my examples into the element that it
understands my schema that I put in
there
>> or can I just push in with my schema
just
>> for which part are you referring let me
go back uh because you mentioned zero so
few so are you talking about
>> no if I want to basically what's the
best method now if I have the perfect
how do I bring it to the LM that it
works properly on or it works better on
knowledge extract
>> because
>> if I have okay
>> from the graph right perspective I'm I
think pretty clear but uh really on that
I want entities and relations out of my
uh so your knowledge minor uh uh
situation if I want to improve that and
have the perfect schema and really did
my work homework now how do I give it to
the
>> so you're referring to you have you have
a nice schema of for your knowledge
graph forget rag for now there's no rag
yet and you want to to populate the
graph
>> okay
you have your schema your schema
contains classes contains relations
contains attributes
to populate. What does it mean?
Populating the knowledge graph means
instantiating classes. So you have a
class customer which means that you need
from your data that you want to mine the
graph to find all the instances that are
classes,
right? Okay. So for that
you start and say okay I want to define
an entity recognizer out of my data. How
can I do that? The first approach would
be as I saw zero shots. This is a
document. Find me the the entities in
the in the in the in the document that
are customers.
Now then this is the most the simplest
thing. If you have a good schema as I
mentioned then you can enhance the
prompt and say a customer is that and
that and that. This is the meaning of a
customer in my context.
>> They are bringing my my welldefined.
Yes, exactly.
>> Yeah. And now what that's the point
where I'm standing right now saying okay
I have the definition that is a customer
right still be struggling to find
customers because they could be clients
they could be organizations they could
be something and
>> yeah the idea the idea and the
expectation is that the more accurate
your prompts are if I go back here sorry
you
Uh
the expectation is sorry
the expectation is that the more the
better your prompt is. So this is a case
where the initial prompt was was
enhanced by means of examples.
By doing that we got a correct
extraction. So
development wise I would think it like
this. I get a test set where I want to
try my extractor. I try it with a simple
prompt. I get 50% precision. For
example, I try it with with a better
prompt by using definitions. Hopefully
it gets better. I add more examples, it
gets better. When I get a level that I
find it satisfying,
I run it and and I do the extraction.
So I will go the annotation way.
Basically, as a knowledge worker, I
build my classes. I build my ontology
and when I ship it to basically, let's
let's call it another team that works on
it. So I have that disparity of okay,
somebody else has to understand it. I
basically ship it together with five
nice examples of that class. So they can
pick that or push these examples as
>> and my suggestion is and my suggestion
is for every class and for every
relation includeam
positive examples and negative examples
counter examples in many cases by
defining what should not be there
already.
to generate examples.
>> Yeah, you can do that.
>> And and then we end up with an ontology
of let's say 200 classes and so on. And
then my my few shots prompts get really
really really really really context
intensive and I have a lot of things
that I have to bring in. So there
>> now you can you can define
>> so that you
>> if you have 200 classes or you can also
that's another thing you can it's also a
matter of implementation and I don't
have a good answer for that whether you
are going to use to have a prompt where
you put all the classes the possible
classes and you ask find me in the
system all the classes or you run one
different prompt for each class for
example
then we go to this type of to to details
of that kind of implementation which I
unfortunately I don't have an answer
what works best or not and of course
>> sustainability because
>> yeah no no of course another important
thing another important thing indeed to
consider
>> another important thing to consider is
indeed this
>> for for many extraction task I showed I
showed here the potential of LLM and
what to be aware of I would say that
indeed to use
an LLM for extra raction task can be in
sometimes an overkill too expensive
too bad for the environment etc. So if
you can
before you use an LLM
you can do basic extraction quite good
extraction with even simple basic rules
you know that work for you go for that
or if you have any system any you have
an existing system for that yeah the are
still expensive expensive data of cost
of course yes
and this is actually a reason why at
least in my company we don't use
uh LLM for extraction for production
at online and online mode. Many things
that we run are offline to populate the
knowledge graph.
>> Yes. How can we find the balance between
the coach to make sure that
whatever we do with the um
graph kg does not kind of like override
the full knowledge of the LLM
>> does not override the knowledge of the
LM
>> like memorization probably he knows the
answer from the LLM but because we felt
um information with KG he's not able to
give us that information because it's
giving us from from the KG actually
instead of what it knows.
>> Yeah, you're saying what? Yeah, I don't
have an answer for that. I don't know if
it's possible to say, you know, take get
this information maybe doing different
steps in your process. So get some you
know split your task with something that
you want to get from the knowledge graph
and something that you want to get from
the LM in general.
Rag in general ra and graph rag has a
bias towards what is in the what you get
from the database from either from the
knowledge graph or or from the document.
The idea that you trust that resource
whe when whereas the LLM you don't trust
as a knowledge provider. What you want
from the LLM in rag is the language
capabilities, the ability to understand
the variation of language, not the facts
themselves.
>> Yeah,
>> I think this question might already been
answered but I might for
modeling recently developed a
application which applies a blockchain
chain process which retrieves a schema
from my graph.
>> Yeah.
>> And then uses that context to refine the
prompt that's then you know generates
the queries to pull out the information.
Would it be a sensible approach to
assign an attribute to the relationships
and the nodes themselves with examples,
you know, to provide a flu shot learning
um approach, you know, in terms of that
chain linkage where the schema
attributes alongside it to provide the
context for the entity.
>> Can you elaborate a bit more? I'm not
sure. So sorry I've got a at the moment
I've got a chain where I query the Neo4j
graph. Yeah. And it pulls out the schema
and it uses that schema then to refine
the user query um so that I'm pulling
out relevant information to answer the
query.
>> Yes. Uh I was just thinking through when
you're talking could it be a possible
route to helping the construction of the
knowledge graph just to provide a schema
up with some attributes alongside it in
terms of you know examples of this is
what this relationship should look like
this
>> what this entity should look like use
that almost as a pre-processing step for
>> sounds plausible what you're describing
yes
>> practically it's part of the content
you're saying you're giving more
information about the relation or
about the extraction task.
>> Yeah.
>> I cannot know if it works or not, you
know, but it's but sounds makes sense
what you're saying. Yes.
Yeah. The whole I mean the whole thing
with LLMs is trying to tell them what
you want and in most of the cases we
don't know what we want.
That's the thing. And um
I I see you know when when you play with
an LLM and you realize that it gives you
a wrong answer it kind of makes you
think is this because the LM doesn't
understand or it's because
it's illdefined what I have uh asked it
to tell me
sometimes is the one sometimes it's the
other and and that's the difficulty
there
even Here I say wrote. What does wrote
mean? You know, wrote the script. Wrote
another question.
Okay.
If you're interested further in the
topic, um
I'm running next uh next spring two
courses. You should have a flyer in your
in your bag. um it's two parallel
courses. One is addressed it's about
building knowledge graph with LLMs. So
it's practically what we've seen in much
more detail and it's mainly for people
for for practitioners who build
knowledge graphs or who want to build
knowledge graphs to accelerate using LLM
and the other course is about building
graph rag applications with knowledge
graph. seeing in more detail how what
different architectural patterns of
graph rag
of course the basics of um checking
knowledge graph etc and very important
evaluation of graph rag and how how you
can debug it right so when your graph
rag doesn't do well
how how can you measure its quality and
how you can uh you can evaluate so if
you're interested you can contact me and
I will let you know it's still uh the
course haven't opened but uh you can
join a wait list and I will let you
know. So yeah, thank you very much. Have
a nice evening.